the Joe Rogan experience I mean I will
say I feel like like there was like a
little piece of my humanity that was
lost when I was in a VR situation where
I came back and I'm like I got lost time
or something yeah well you said it's
best that it's more fun sometimes than
regular life and it's crude yeah when
it's complicated
yeah this is the argument for simulation
theory the argument for simulation
theory is we know it's coming one day if
things keep if you go back to like the
mom I don't think it's already here it
might be I don't know I don't know if
you go back like the Model T and then
look at like a modern brand-new BMW at
the amount of technology of this shift
is so radical and so so crazy and not
that long 100 years or so imagine what
it's going to be like a hundred years
from now because things just speeding
we're still gonna be alive apparently
probably so the stuff that we're seeing
now in terms of virtual reality this is
just a tip of the iceberg yeah yeah
that's weird
it's some freaky [ __ ] you're gonna be
able to stay home and do concerts so
that's the goal fully immersive like
someone's onstage with you live show I
don't know if you're right I do I do
know if you're right I think you're
right I think you're right but I don't
know if you're right and I don't think i
think we're limited to what we're we're
we understand people are capable of
right now I don't I think until our
actual like resources collapse and you
can't go outside and you have to live in
a bubble nothing can replace a live
music show or a live comedy show like
when you're right there I think you're
right for now until the VR gives you the
like breath wind on your face and the
[ __ ] heat from the pyrotechnics or
whatever by the way I was at the Grammys
when you played and the pyrotechnics
were I was like there was fire I don't
think they're very far away from being
able to transmit a
more immersive experiences call me a
purist [ __ ] sucks sucks you're gonna
get a bunch of people that are just no
you first
the question is don't forget your
thought that's not the question that was
that was a request the question is I
can't is I can't believe that you could
replace check me out here
yeah thanks friend the energy that you
get from a live performance with virtual
reality I can't believe or subscribe to
that thought that it is going to be
manufactured digitally like you can get
effects of the sensory stuff with the
sound and the visual and maybe even have
machinery that gives you physical like
air or heat or cold or whatever it would
you know simulate that thing but I can't
at the core of my being thinks think
that you could you could substitute the
energy that you feel when you connect
with a group roomful of people
cheers love you guys this is so much fun
salute do you know I'm saying I do I
completely agree with you but I don't
okay I saw Tupac live at Coachella right
Tupac go super jacked but was that the
same thing no no it's not the same thing
but I'm kind of in the middle like yeah
this is what I think I really think this
like right now you're right right now
you can't be out of a show where you're
on stage live and get that same exact
experience if you were at home on a
computer or with a VR goggle I feel like
right now yes but in the future oh they
might be able to get to the point where
it's better to do it through VR cuz I'm
standing right next to you while you're
singing on stage last not
the intimacy of the crowd experience
where one can look to your neighbors and
be like [ __ ] yes so right
[Applause]